in the frozen borderlands tensions are
growing over the build-up of russian
troops
ukrainian soldiers peering out of
trenches at an enemy that surrounds them
the uk is now offering more military
support to nato and is warning the
kremlin to expect tough new sanctions if
it does launch an invasion
currently the economic sanctions are
fairly narrowly drawn
so we could only target companies with a
direct involvement in destabilizing
ukraine
what we are looking to do is widen that
so any company of interest to
the kremlin and the regime in russia
would be able to be targeted
seizing russian assets could be a
powerful weapon but experts say moscow
is unlikely to be concerned about the
british government's threats
sending tanks to estonia improves the
defense of the baltic states somewhat
although not hugely because we don't
have all the other things there we need
like air and missile defense to make it
a really
credible defence in the baltics but
while london continues to be the
money laundering haven for
peptocratic regimes in russia and
elsewhere no one's going to take liz
trust very seriously
and this is the reality on the ground
ukrainian troops continuing to train in
how to use high-tech weaponry provided
by western allies
the prime minister boris johnson was
briefed by defence chiefs this week and
is urging russia to engage in
negotiations
his foreign and defense secretaries are
now preparing for talks in moscow
there is no plan to deploy nato forces
to ukraine but member states in eastern
europe could soon be bolstered
uk already has 900 combat troops in
estonia and more than 100 military
trainers in ukraine
boris johnson is now offering to double
the number of soldiers deployed to nato
he'll also send fast jets warships and
more military specialists if required
they join more than 3 000 troops from
other nato countries who are already
operating in eastern europe
the facts on ukraine's border though
tell their own story russia has a
significant force around 130 000 troops
in all
but it continues to claim that it is the
victim of nato expansion
the line they are supposed to defend is
moving to the right let nato console
themselves by saying that it is
defensive it doesn't make things easier
for us
there is no doubt this is a dangerous
moment and what happens next is far from
clear
but the west is for now hoping that
deterrence and diplomacy will be enough
to avert a catastrophic invasion alex
rossi sky news